-Republicans are blaming
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
on President Biden
and claiming
it wouldn't have happened
under Donald Trump,
while Trump muses
about bombing Russia
but pretending
it was someone else.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's worth remembering,
in a moment
of international crisis
like the one we're in right now,
that we came incredibly close
to having this criminal dingus
in charge of our response.
I mean, can you imagine?
Can you imagine what things
would be like
with Donald Trump
at the helm right now?
I mean,
put aside everything else,
have you heard him talk lately?
He sounds like he's
muttering to himself
while sitting
under his favorite tree
at the old folks' home,
after getting his morphine drip
topped off.
-Yesterday, reporters asked me
if I thought President Putin
was smart.
I said, "Of course, he's smart,"
to which I was greeted with,
"Oh, that's such a terrible
thing to say."
I like to tell the truth.
Yes, he's smart.
The NATO nations and,
indeed, the world
as he looks over
what's happening strategically,
with no repercussions
or threats whatsoever,
they're not so smart.
They're looking
the opposite of smart.
"If you take over Ukraine,
we're going to sanction you,"
they say.
Sanction? Well, that's
a pretty weak statement.
-God, I wish I knew where his
teleprompter was during that.
[ Laughter ]
What is with
that soft tone of voice?
Is he doing storytime
at the local library?
"The pig says
'We're gonna sanction you,'
to which the goose replies,
'Oh, that's such
a terrible thing to say.'
But do you see?
Do you see the pig?
Do you see how weak he looks?"
[ Laughter ]
Sometimes I wonder
what happened.
Did you get shot with a
tranquilizer dart 18 months ago,
but because you drink
so many Diet Cokes,
it's taking forever to kick in?
[ Laughter ]
"Vladimir Putin --
he's looking at us,
and he's thinking --
'They're weak. They're awake.'"
[ Laughter ]
I like when Trump's voice
gets really soft like that,
when he does this helium voice.
That's when you know
even he's like,
"I don't know what the [Bleep]
I'm talking about."
I think his strategy is
just to make it so soft,
you can't hear
what he's saying anymore.
"They asked me what I would do
about Ukraine.
I said, 'I know
exactly what I would do.
I know exactly --
I know ex-- I know
exactly what I would do.
I was as anxious [Mumbling].'"
[ Laughter ]
As a reminder,
that guy used to be
the commander in chief
of our armed forces,
and he came very close
to pulling off a coup
that would have kept him
in that position.
In fact,
he very likely committed
several crimes in the process,
as we learned last week
from the committee investigating
the Jan. 6th insurrection,
-The January 6th committee
going farther than it has before
in its investigation of
former President Donald Trump.
Lawmakers now saying
they have evidence
suggesting
former President Trump
and his attorney
committed crimes,
including fraud,
after the 2020 election
and in the lead-up
to the Capitol riot.
-This morning,
the Jan. 6th committee
saying for the first time
that it believes
former President Donald Trump
committed crimes
after the 2020 election,
writing in a new legal filing
that it has reason to believe
Trump and his campaign
"engaged in"
a criminal conspiracy
to defraud the United States."
-First of all,
this whole January 6th committee
is taking too long.
You know how I know?
There's already been another
January 6th at the calendar.
Second of all, you're
just now reaching the conclusion
that was obvious at the time?
This is like
the medical examiner
showing up to a murder scene
and saying,
"Oh, yeah, no,
he's definitely dead."
That's why we called you!
[ Laughter ]
So a president who likely
committed several crimes
to remain in power
was very nearly at the helm
in a moment of heightened
tensions with nuclear power.
And as terrifying
as that prospect is,
it's even more terrifying
to imagine
who would have been around him,
because a second
Trump administration
was guaranteed
to be fully unrestrained
and filled almost entirely
with the rogues' gallery
of kooks and weirdos
who have continued
to stick with Trump
throughout the attempted coup
and its aftermath --
people like
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell,
who's still insisting
he's going to take down
the supposedly rigged
voting machines,
as he told the crowd yet again
over the weekend.
-I'm going to
tell you right now,
we're doing -- I've been
working on it five months,
and we're doing
a class action --
I'm announcing it here.
It's a class action lawsuit
against all machines
and that they're
defective devices.
Okay?
I have lawyers
worked on this for five months.
-Are you sure they're lawyers?
Like, in the meetings --
okay -- are they wearing
suits and ties?
Are they holding
legal documents,
or are they in white coats
and making you --
Are they showing you
inkblot tests, like,
and saying,
"What does this look like?"
"A rigged election."
"And this one?"
"Uh, the election was rigged."
"And what about this?"
"Hugo Chávez?
No, wait. Rigged election."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Mike Lindell, though,
and he's announcing it here,
which is a pretty big deal.
[ Laughter ]
Mike Lindell wants to file
a class-action lawsuit
against all machines.
[ Laughter ]
What other machines
is he including in that?
"I'm filing a lawsuit
against election machine,
fax mach-- vending machines,
and those things
at amusement parks
that flatten pennies,
because one time I-I --
True story. I put a pen-
I can't believe
I'm announcing it here.
I put a penny in
and it got stuck,
and I complained
at Mickey Mouse,
and they kicked me out
before I could go
to the Jamboree with da Bears."
Look, we came very close --
very close to a world
where Trump was still in charge
during Russia's brutal
and illegal invasion of Ukraine,
which is scary for many reasons,
one of which is Trump
keeps giving us a glimpse
as to how
he would have responded.
And as usual, he has
that unique Trump blend
of being both terrifying
and incredibly stupid
at the same time.
According to
"The Washington Post,"
Trump mused Saturday
to the GOP's top donors
that the United States
should label its F-22 planes
with the Chinese flag
and "bomb the [Bleep]
out of Russia.
And then we say,
China did it.
We didn't do it.
And then they start fighting
with each other
and we sit back and watch."
He definitely
gets his ideas from cartoons.
I mean, this is a slightly
stupider version
of Bugs Bunny dressing up
as a sexy lady
to distract Elmer Fudd.
"We put the Chinese flags
on the plane,
and if that doesn't work,
we paint a tunnel
on the side of a mountain.
We do.
And then our jets -- our jets --
they go right
through the tunnel.
No problem.
But the Russ--
the Russian jets are gonna
crash right into them.
And then our jets, they're gonna
hold up a little sign
that says 'Meep meep!'
and that --
t-that -- that -- t-that --
that -- that --
t-that's all, folks."
[ Laughter ]
This has always
been Trump's way.
He used to float crazy [Bleep]
like this all the time
as a candidate and as president.
Like the time,
he reportedly suggested
using a nuclear bomb
to stop a hurricane,
which prompted one lawmaker
to introduce a bill
that would prohibit presidents
from nuking hurricanes.
First of all, how is that not
just, like, a one-sentence bill?
Call it the "Sigh, No,
You Can't Nuke a Hurricane,
You Dip[Bleep] JFC Act
of 2020."
Second, I love
when they have to pass a law
that technically applies
to all presidents,
but is specifically
aimed at Trump.
It's like when
your co-worker at Chipotle
gets caught wrapping his junk
in a tortilla,
and the manager has to make
a new rule for everyone
because of it.
"Alright, guys,
there's a new sign
up in the break room.
'No wrapping your private parts
in the tortilla anymore.'
This applies, of course,
to all of you,
but we are
calling it the Same Rule."
[ Laughter ]
Trump's dumb ideas were always
rebuffed by his generals,
but who the hell knows
who he would have hired
in the second term
after getting away with a coup?
For all we know,
he could have made Lindell
chairman of the Joint Chiefs,
and we'd all be surrendering
our toasters to the government
as part of the war on...
-All machines.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And you can't
let any of them off the hook.
In this case, I think I know
where Trump probably
got this insane idea.
Last week, one of
his closest confidants,
Fox News host Sean Hannity,
had a similar idea,
which he floated multiple times,
including on his radio show.
You see, NATO and the U.S.
can't get involved militarily.
Otherwise, the conflict
would drastically escalate
and spiral out of control.
But Hannity's brilliant strategy
for getting around all that
was having a NATO country
bomb a Russian convoy,
but then just don't tell them
who it was.
Do you genuinely think
that's how it works?
It's a mystery unless
someone takes credit for it?
It's an aerial bombing,
not a fart at a dinner party.
[ Laughter ]
"Okay, just sit still,
be quiet, and no one will think
it's you, Sean.
Sean, did you pass gas?"
"Why would you say that?"
"Because it's the first time
I've ever seen you be quiet."
[ Laughter ]
And of course, it won't
surprise you to learn
that the same party
that spent four years
apologizing for Trump's praise
of autocrats and dictators,
and is currently floating
insane theories
for how to stop the war,
are also now claiming
this would have never happened
under Trump's watch.
-This never would have happened
under Trump.
-Joe Biden becoming president
is the best thing
that ever happened,
tragically, for Vladimir Putin.
-We've seen a Russian dictator
now terrorize
the Ukrainian people
because America
didn't demonstrate the resolve
that we did
for the four years prior.
-They didn't do this
on Trump's watch, Russia,
because Trump would have
kicked their ass.
"He would have kicked their ass,
but he would have done it
with a shoe that said 'China'
on the bottom.
So, when they looked
at their pants later,
they'd say, 'Ha-ha,
now I know, kick my ass.'
And then a war would start
between those two countries,
and we'd be walking
on Easy Street."
[ Laughter ]
I can't believe -- and, yes,
of course, I can believe --
that I have to remind you guys
that Trump not only tried
to weaken NATO and the West,
but also specifically held up
aid to Ukraine
as part of an attempt
to cheat in the election
and dig up dirt on Joe Biden.
Remember that?
That was the entire
first impeachment.
One day, we're all going to
have to go back
and rewatch
the entire Trump presidency
without hitting
the "skip recap" button.
[ Laughter ]
And when you point all that out
to Trump loyalists,
like his former
U.N. ambassador Nikki Haley,
the best they can say
in Trump's defense is,
"Sure, he tried
to help Putin out,
but he didn't succeed."
-The Trump administration --
Trump personally tried
to roll back sanctions on Russia
in 2017.
He did.
They tried to lobby Congress
to weaken Russian sanctions
and legislation in 2017.
He tried to remove sanctions
on a Russian oligarch company
in 2018.
Delayed chemical-weapons
sanctions that were required
by law against Russia.
And let's not forget, holding
Ukrainian military aid hostage
for a political stunt.
How didn't --
You don't think
any of those things
sent a message to Vladimir Putin
that America is divided,
the West is divided, and he can
get away with whatever he wants?
-You said it in every one
of those things.
You kept saying, "He tried."
All I know is what he did.
-"Yeah, Chuck,
he tried to help Putin,
but he was too stupid
to follow through.
So, um, checkmate, libs."
[ Laughter ]
I get it now --
trying is different
from doing,
so it's only a crime
if you successfully rob a bank,
not if you try to rob a bank
but then the teller says,
"Isn't that a stapler?"
and you say,
"Uh, no, uh, this is a gun."
And then someone else
looks at it and says,
"Office Depot
doesn't make guns,"
and you say, "Shut up!"
So then you try to steal a pen
without realizing
the pen is chained to the desk,
so you get yanked
and you fall backwards
and you split your pants,
and everyone at the bank
starts laughing.
You're sweating so bad,
you take off your mask
and someone says,
"There's a camera, you idiot."
And you look up and you realize
you're staring straight into
the security camera,
and you say, "Guys,
this doesn't count, okay?
I only tried to rob the bank,
but I didn't do it, so shut up."
And then the video gets uploaded
to YouTube, and it goes viral.
So, to stop it,
you file a lawsuit against...
-All machines.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
All -- Every one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The point is, if you're a person
with any power at all,
and you want to do something
about the crisis,
maybe try helping
the 1.7 million refugees
who have fled Ukraine so far,
the many others
who are still there
and need our solidarity.
That would be
a lot more productive
than pitching insane ideas
for starting World War III.
No one wants to hear that.
Even the people at your
fundraisers are thinking...
-"Oh, that's such a terrible
thing to say."
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.